hi i'm conan o'brien welcome to serious
jibber jabber peter goralnek is one of
america's preeminent music writers and
historians his two books on elvis
presley are recognized as the gold
standard of music biographies and have
been praised for stripping away the myth
and focusing on elvis the musician
his other work includes an equally
acclaimed biography of sam cook entitled
dream boogie and he's currently putting
the finishing touches on the life story
of sun records owner
sam phillips
this is stuff i really love to talk
about so peter growling thank you for
indulging me in being here well thank
you i'm really excited to be here uh
let's uh
begin
by mentioning that you were on my late
night show
and we were chatting and i had such a
good time talking to you that i thought
we must continue this conversation
that was 19 years ago it takes me a
while to get to things but thanks for
finally making this happen well it's
it's good to be able to have that uh you
know the sequel yeah
and we have a little more time now and
i'm a little more experienced
uh let's get right into it um i am a
big elvis presley fan
and
had read just about every book i thought
on elvis and then your two volumes came
along
and
completely reorganized my thinking
about
elvis and changed everything and i think
the biggest contribution of those books
especially the first book is that you
you stripped away
all the layers of myth
and all the iconography
and all of these sort of ironic joking
about elvis
and you got back to this kid
this incredible kid this 19 year old
uh with an amazing talent who changes
the world right
what inspired you to do that
well you know that was i mean the
intention really was to go back to a
time
when you didn't know how it was all
going to come out
and the funny thing is the two things
that inspired it
uh were one i was driving down
macklemore avenue where um
in south memphis
where stax records uh was and where the
stax museum is now and i was driving
down with a friend who had grown up in
south memphis and she pointed out right
across the street from the old movie
theater that was stacks
a boarded-up drugstore
where elvis's cousin jean used to work
this is way back before i even thought
about the book
and she just described how elvis would
be in there waiting for gene to get off
work and she said you know he'd be
sitting at the counter
and his fingers would just be drumming
you know he was just so he was
hyperactive and she said and then she
just said poor baby
and i just had this flash of inspiration
i mean this was a kid this is a kid as
you said he was just consumed with music
i mean any kid who was into music or in
a sense who's consumed with anything
like that should be able to understand
it he was just absolutely and but but he
was also just a kid
who had dreams but had no you know had
no
means of achieving them and that was the
kid that i really wanted to get back to
the other thing and this was
almost an equal revelation for me was i
i worked i started working on this
documentary about elvis this was at a
time you know pre-internet when
the
all the interviews that elvis did i mean
i just didn't wasn't aware of them they
were not accessible
and the documentarians the two people
who were making the thing got together
all these interviews he had done in 55
and 56 and suddenly it struck me as oh
my god elvis can speak for himself and
that was really the intention of the
book was to have him speak for himself
and to write a book that was written i
mean this is what i've tried to do with
everything i've ever written to write a
book that was written from the inside
out
that wasn't just looking at some mythic
thing or oh look this guy came down from
another planet right it basically
was trying to understand the world that
he was looking at and how he responded
to it well uh i got the opportunity the
honor to to interview david halberstam
a number of years before he passed away
and he had written a book about fifth
called the 50s
and i asked him what do you think was
the most significant event in the 50s
and we're talking about
uh you've got everything you've got the
korean war and uh you've got uh mccarthy
and you've got all these huge seminal
events
and i said and civil rights and
everything i said what was the biggest
thing and he said elvis
elvis was
the event
that uh was the most explosive even
including the hydrogen bomb he said more
than the hydrogen bomb elvis presley
right do you agree with that
you know i don't know how you compare
things like that i i think that elvis
was a focal point and and and i mean and
in fact
on some level i don't know that elvis
would agree with that
because what i think that elvis elvis
saw elvis was
he was like an ethnomusicologist without
a degree i mean you could not have met
anyone who knew more about music of
every kind of music he listened to the
metropolitan opera he would go to the uh
all night uh singings at uh ellis
auditorium which was across the street
from the public housing where he grew up
and they really weren't all night but
these were the gospel quartet singings
he knew everything about white gospel
music he knew everything about black
gospel music he just soaked everything
up you know
like litmus paper but he uh
it's i i would say
more so than elvis that the 20th century
really witnessed the triumph of american
vernacular culture
and that elvis was part of a movement
you're part of a continuum and you could
include duke ellington you could you
could include louis armstrong you could
include hank williams howland wolfe beau
didley
and for elvis i think he saw he just had
the widest scope imaginable and this
encompassed
every major social racial cultural
development and it also went on in a
sense
i think the entire movement
to
to create as great a cultural
contribution as america has ever made to
the world it won it won over the world
so it expands beyond it extends beyond
our borders and i think that that for me
is what it is but no elvis there's no
limit in a sense to what you can put
into elvis achievement
whether intended or not
i mean it touched every aspect of our
lives i when i was in college
um
and it's the 80s
and i had sort of come of age with 60s
and 70s music
and
uh
elvis wasn't a big interest of mine
and then
i want to say 1983
i listened for the first time to the sun
sessions uh elvis's earliest work that
he did with sam phillips and it blew my
mind it just
i couldn't it was like a drug i couldn't
get enough of it it made me go out and
buy a guitar it made me try and play
that music and in a sense i've never
gotten past that music i can't get past
early elvis i can't get past jerry lee
lewis i can't get past carl perkins i
appreciate the other music but i'm
always drawn back it's just this energy
because it
it's coming out of the initial explosion
of
all the
i don't know you'd know understand
better than i would but all these
socio-economic events are there
all the cultural events are there and
then in memphis this thing happened
yeah now it's the confluence of all
these influences the confluences of all
these different cultures i mean memphis
was
just at the heart of everything and when
you think about sam phillips who
recorded all of these uh artists to
begin with and recorded b.b king
recorded howland wolfe recorded ike
turner recorded just dr ross you know
the one-man band
little junior parker
but what
what it brought together i mean in a
sense it was it was a plot
to undermine
the
sense of separateness that dominated
american culture and it was very much
what sam phillips envisioned from the
moment that he first opened the studio
on january 2nd 1950 that he made that
declaration to begin with and if you
listen it's an amazing thing you listen
to bb king's first recordings that he
made for
for sam phillips so you listen to howlin
wolf and what sam was aiming for
was rock and roll without there being
any title to it it was just a
combination of all these different
influences in this rhythmic drive
and it was a sense of exuberance i think
that that more than anything else and
you get that sometimes i mean i really
dug the band that was on your show
tonight
but but i mean the point is that so
often
uh
you know music can take on a kind of
affectation i mean an a of attitude or
whatever well rock and roll is continue
it's always
uh
it becomes
laden with all this stuff which can be
great but rock and roll is constantly
drifting or pop music is constantly
drifting away and you're getting
orchestras and you're getting
you know um
people are auto-tuned and then it gets
stripped away and people bring it back
punk was all about saying let's reclaim
this let's reclaim this uh rock and roll
is not for
really gifted musicians in styx
or rush it's for
people like us who only play two or
three chords but we have this feeling
that we need to express
well yeah and sam sam spoke about giving
voice to those who didn't have voice and
he also spoke
uh in a sense just about
about this
sense of perfect imperfection right
perfection is boring but what you wanted
was the perfect realization of this
imperfect striving
now the the what what's so interesting i
mean i i think i had you know very much
the same experience with elvis that you
did in the sense of what brought me to
elvis was the blues i mean i just fell
into the blues when i was 15 or
15 or 16 and i just i mean i never
turned back and it was i hadn't heard
the sun recordings until
after that i mean i had heard elvis's
popular recordings but
uh when he was in the army in 59 or 60
rca had no product to put out and they
put out two albums uh
that it contained most of the sun
recordings and i recognized them i
recognized that's all right i knew
aren't the crudups that's all right i
recognized
mystery train i mean i knew a little
junior parkers and it wasn't that
elvis's versions were placed at but it
was so pure and it was so out of time
and that's what i think is so
interesting about his early music or
jerry lee lewis's early music is if you
didn't know it was rock and roll you'd
be hard-pressed to find a name for it
right because it's so much itself you
listen to that that's all right or
mystery train and you just listen to
that trio recording just his elvis
acoustic guitar scotty moore's electric
guitar slapping bass and what does that
have to do with rock and roll as it's
defined and very literally i mean it it
just it's it's it's its own self and
that i think is what's absolutely that's
what's enabled it to continue to have a
life of its own it's what's so
extraordinary about it is that it lives
outside of
it's not it's not running after a trend
it's not it's just creating its own
sound let's step back and and create
this moment because you have sam
phillips sam phillips is a very unusual
guy
um he's kind of manic he's very gifted
uh and uh but he has this kind of drive
this this drive to
uh bring black white music together get
rid of the the racial barrier he sets up
his own
studio sun sun studios
he knows scotty moore scotty moore knows
bill black
so he's got these musicians now the
great fable is that elvis just wanders
in off the street he's a truck driver
for crown electric
and magic happens that's the movie
version right what i was struck by when
i read your books is i realized elvis
kept coming back he went to sun studios
many times
recorded it didn't click he would sing
ballads he would try things he would
hang around
and it was
only when scottie moore is looking for a
singer and
and that that and sam phillips says well
let's try that kid again and he comes by
and and even that session almost didn't
work they're trying and trying and
trying it doesn't work
and then elvis is goofing around and he
just starts to play that's all right
mama right and that's when the whole
thing happened right right so to me it
always felt like it wasn't an accident
elvis somehow knew
he had something
and he kept coming back he's like a
salmon swimming upstream he probably
doesn't even know why he's doing it but
he just kept coming to sun studios
because he
if you have that kind of talent on some
subconscious level you must know it
well yeah i mean elvis was this guy who
had played had not played out in public
in any way shape or form right he's a
guy who practiced in front of the mirror
he's like a kid you know practicing air
guitarics i mean he got a guitar and he
did there were other kids in the uh in
lauderdale courts who
were more accomplished and he hung
around with them to some extent but he
didn't play with a band he didn't right
and he uh but but what he did have was
he had an innate belief in himself for
all of his insecurity
he believed in an almost mystical way
both he and his mother
had a vision very early in in his life
of his achieving a kind of success that
neither one of them could have named
neither one of them could have all
together pictured
and i don't i don't think he ever had a
doubt that he was going to get there but
where where there was was not
was not exactly clear
yeah and he put himself in the way of
discovery it's almost like a guy who
uses his shyness to make a hit with
girls he just kind of you know hangs
around he he uses his vulnerability
to draw attention to himself
and elvis
went in there he cut that first record i
mean actually if you hear the acetate
which miraculously survived if you
listen to my happiness and that's when
your heartaches begin you hear all the
vulnerability i mean you can barely play
the guitar right but you hear all the
vulnerability you you're all of the
feeling you it's such an unusual thing
you don't have it's not a trained voice
it's some but it's something that that
communicates better
than so then so many trained voices and
so many of the artists that elvis
admired because they were such great
singers better singers than elvis but
even in that first thing at 19 or 18
actually
he was able to get that and then he
write he kept coming back and coming
back
just to he he
struck up a friendship with marion
kaiser i mean like so many women
marrying kaiser who was sam phillips
assistant just she was the assistant who
sort of was the gatekeeper right and she
just you know she fell in love with him
yeah i mean in in and
and i think she uh
helped advance his cause with sam and
then eventually
uh
scotty moore uh was and bill black were
in a band and as you say uh
scotty was looking for a singer who
could who could who could travel
everybody else everybody had a day job
and nobody else was going to travel and
and uh so they brought so
elvis uh
elvis had a rehearsal with scotty at his
house
went into the studio and sang nothing
but balance yeah and they're beautiful
ballads but nothing even remotely like
well the thing that blew me away is that
the people you know uh
the people that elvis really admired who
influenced him among them are
bing crosby and dean martin yeah he
wanted to sound like
dean martin and you can hear it once
once i read that i made the connection
you listen to elvis and that kind of and
you hear bing crosby too the the low
bass notes and the kind of the syrupy
kind of
you know you have some sense of
relaxation yeah you can hear it but
if you i'd never make that connection on
my own he was listening to everything
and some of the influences you'd never
guess in a million years well i mean he
wanted to sound like bill county of the
ink spots you can hear that but when he
said when he recorded that's when your
heartaches began on his acetate he also
wanted to sing like i think was hoppy
jones with the bass singer so you've got
him singing you know the tenor part
and he wanted to sound like clyde
mcfadder you know who became the who was
the lead singer with the drifters with
this beautiful
tenor i mean he he would have killed for
something like that he wanted to sound
like jake hess who was a kind of almost
operatic singer for the statesman for
the statesman gospel quartet but what he
brought to it was something that was so
recognizably himself right from the
beginning and that's the thing that you
know nobody you can hear people who
create a sound that's like another sound
and who have a lot of success right
but what you can't create is that sense
of cutting through everything else i
mean i remember jake house saying to me
jake house was just a great great singer
this is the guy who was the lead singer
for the statesman
and he said
you know elvis would hang around when
they were playing when they were
performing at these all-night singings i
i said what did you remember him did you
pick him up he said you couldn't miss
him
he was just such an amazi i can't
remember what the phrase is but he was
he stood out he was such an amazing kid
because he had such a drive he had such
a and when he sang i mean jake has
recognized this he wasn't like the great
singers he wasn't like roy hamilton yeah
who was in fact almost an operatic
singer he's saying you never walk alone
but he communicated
in a way that no other singer did
somebody like sam cook communicated in
the same way you had so many people who
sounded like sam cook
but no one who communicated and you and
you can't write a prescription for that
no the what's interesting is elvis
as we know it all takes off but it's
like anything else people think it's
preordained but elvis
uh
you know that's all right mama they
start touring
and he's not
a great live performer and in fact
bill black doesn't get enough credit the
bass player he would sometimes carry
them in shows because he could clown
around and stand on the base and and his
antics would sometimes take them through
the show
it all happened pretty quickly for elvis
but when you break it down
you feel like it could all fall apart at
any moment
well it could and yet given elvis drive
the drive that you don't see at first i
mean for somebody who sam phillips said
was the most insecure the most markedly
insecure person
he had ever run into he said he had the
insecurity of some of the black singers
that he worked with
that sam worked with right
and yet for all of that insecurity he
was just heading in this direction and
what was amazing was that
his records went when it came across i
mean when that's all right came out
uh
the um you know that thing where he says
you know this became a watch word in
memphis not every i mean very few people
had seen him right but it was the voice
that communicated when he first appeared
on louisiana hayride all these kids came
out from a local college and they came
out to hear somebody who had only
communicated with him through the sound
of his voice right and when he appeared
and he appeared in the middle of all
these professional uh
groups uh the maddox brothers and rose i
mean they had been the stars a week
before people who had the most you know
highly polished and developed acts and
elvis just had something that he was
feeling his way towards and if anybody
wants to see it they can watch his
appearances uh on the dorsey brothers
shows which started in early 56 and you
can see over the course of six shows how
rapidly his his uh you know his
performing style evolves yeah um but but
it there was something about him
that uh you know that that was not to be
denied and even if it was crude
i feel like there was a couple of years
obviously there's a couple of years
there when it all first explodes
and
no one knows what to do with him meaning
obviously the the colonel
uh
knew how to bring elvis
to the heights
as a business you know and as uh as a
recording artist and as a movie artist
but
everyone treats him like a gimmick he's
a gimmick to
america i remember asking my mom once do
you remember when you first saw
elvis presley on tv and she said oh yes
well i was my mother was in law school
at the time and she said oh i just
thought it was the crudest
you know how could this ha and i said
mom it's elvis what do you mean why
didn't you
understand that this was fantastic and
of course she didn't a lot of people
didn't and so you have steve allen
mocking elvis and making him dress up in
a tuxedo and sing hound dog to a puppy
you know right right
they turn it into schtick because nobody
understands that it's a real
huge
natural phenomenon is happening so he's
a gimmick for a long time and everyone's
trying to just figure out how do we how
do we use this gimmick well this was at
a time when vernacular culture was just
absolutely scoring when i started
writing about music
one of the great thrills for me i mean i
did for no you know i did out of nothing
but enthusiasm for the music and one of
the great thrills was being able to
write the name muddy waters in print to
write holland wolf it was nowhere these
i mean this sounds crazy but there was
no above ground publication it was going
to consider it because it was just
considered sort of beneath contempt i
mean you didn't even now without without
i'm sorry but well i'm just curious why
why is it that even to this day
you've changed the game a lot for elvis
and the way that he's considered but
still there's a there's a
condescending attitude about elvis fans
there's a condescending attitude about
elvis that you don't find
say with the beatles of the rolling
stones do you agree with that well you
don't find it with jerry lee lewis
either oddly enough i mean i i can't
really i mean when i started writing
about elvis this was the only thing i
was writing about the within a certain
framework wasn't cool i mean you write
about mario wolf you wrote about jerry
lee lewis your edible blue those are
cool guys to write about elvis was not
when i mean it was nice is it vegas and
the jumpsuit no this was pre-vegas it
was probably the you know it was the
movies i would say more than anything
but but the thing the only thing i'd go
back to
is this was a clear delineation this
this is both a class prejudice and a
regional prejudice that uh because when
elvis was a regional star in the
mid-south and and then reaching out to
texas to oklahoma
there was no hold back there was no hold
back about his face there's a film of
elvis and that performing in 1955 at
magnolia gardens in houston
it's in the afternoon it's a beer garden
but this is an afternoon show and it's
all ages you see little kids you see
middle-aged people they are just
absolutely delighted there's no holdback
there's no shock there's nothing it was
only when elvis became a kind of
national phenomenon which was in the
spring of 56 really when he appeared on
milton berle yeah that all of a sudden
all the
uh i don't know what you call them not
the censors but the
uh all the people who snobs as well
there's not only snobs they're also the
people whether they're ministers
or they're politicians who can call
attention to themselves by saying that's
terrible that's so shocking that's awful
and that had never happened before
that's actually the reason that steve
allen dressed him up in the tuxedo was
because there was a huge movement to
throw him off of the show for him not to
appear after the milton brill
appearances right
because he needs to be censored but i
guess all i'm saying is there was there
was there was in the remains just as
there remains racial prejudice to an
extent that we you know
we often don't recognize there was a
there was a class prejudice that you
know this is the way people will talk
about rednecks you know
uh and there was also there was a
regional prejudice and it came into play
only when elvis crossed the mason-dixon
line only when he became a national
phenomenon comes up to new york and he
starts performing for the entire country
right and people have a problem with it
it's funny the
uh
you touched on the movies and
it felt to me
that in the 50s everyone thought that
rock and roll is a fad so it's something
that you wanted to survive meaning you
wanted a career intact after rock and
roll
so if you look at late buddy holly
before he dies he's getting more
interested in producing
strings there was a whole
attempt i think in the early 60s to say
like rock and roll is over do you know
what i mean that that that happened but
now we're cleaning we're going to kill
it you want to kill it and get more
acceptable
you know let's get um you know uh
um
what's his name from the beach blanket
movies you know more excited frankie
avalon let's get frankie avalon
let's replace these guys who threaten us
let's clean this up and this and
sometimes a lot of times the stars
themselves are eager to
survive and
become legitimate there's something with
elvis where you feel after he gets back
from the army he wanted to be thought of
his first appearance as with frank
sinatra but who is pretty cool
appearance though great appearance but
there's this sense that
now he wants to graduate to i'm tired of
being
the freak show and i'm tired of being
the lightning rod for everybody's
anger adulation i'm tired of being now i
just i i want to make movies in
hollywood they're a good box office i
want to be
a legitimate star is there something
does that make sense
i want to be i want to be
i want parents to accept me
i i think it's there's partially that's
true because the whole path to stardom i
mean when you mentioned colonel parker
before who was a brilliant manager right
but who uh and a revolutionary manager
who who really uh saw the movies in much
the way that the same way that mtd mtv
developed where the music sold the
movies the movie saw the music uh which
made sense up to a point but for elvis
elvis never had confined his ambition to
one thing he wanted to be a a big movie
star he wanted to be james dean
exactly
and uh and he also didn't want to
confine himself to one type of music
right and one of the extraordinary
things that he does when he came out
came out of the army and i'm not an
elvis apologist i mean i'm willing to
talk about
you know but but if you listen to the
session
the sessions he did in the immediate
aftermath of getting out of the army in
in march in april or february and march
of 1960 it's it's the album that came
out was called elvis back and it's such
an extraordinary range of material from
reconsider baby which is what i wanted
which is this low folsom blues where
he's playing an acoustic guitar to you
know solo meow it's now or never yeah
that's what he wanted to do and he
wanted to cover the entire range of
things
uh but i think the the movies are a very
peculiar thing and i don't have the
answer to it but if you watch
if you watch the four movies that he
made before he went in the army right
you see him love me tender he'd never
even been in a high school play and you
see here's a kid who comes out there
he's 21 years old he's memorized the
entire script everybody's part
and he's so eager to do it and he has no
idea how to do it and he's but he's just
totally you know totally
into it but it's not a good performance
but the enthusiasm is there but he's
getting better and better and better in
each of the each of the next three
movies you see him engage more and more
he studies stanislavski yeah i mean he's
totally into the stanislavski method
he wouldn't take acting lessons but he's
he's aware of that and his and his
performance is as much listening in the
la in the last two movies in king creel
and uh jailhouse rock it's as much
listening as it is you know acting now i
can't for the life of me i've had no
idea what happened i mean his mother
died and this really that's huge that's
huge because he had
uh
he
has this connection with his
mom
that he doesn't have with his dad
um
i wasn't disparaging his questions with
his dad but he has this thing with his
mom that's almost mystical
[Music]
and his mom
uh dies
and
it's
at this time when he's also confronting
going he's terrified about going to the
army because he thinks this is going to
end his career he's convinced of it and
he's and he's in the army when his
mother dies yeah and he's in the he's in
the army and he and he falls apart i
mean he falls apart and then uh
you get the sense that his mom was
really his
she had so much belief in him he was so
close to his mom
that something happened there it's no
coincidence to me that he gets back from
the army and what i've always noticed
about elvis that bothers me to this day
is there's nobody who's more talented
there's nobody who's better looking he's
got he is a rare example of the complete
package
and he is at the right time and as roy
orbison said he's the firstest with the
mostest right he's got it all
and he is passive
he doesn't like the songs they give him
in the movies but he sings them he
doesn't like the movies but he does them
why was he so passive you know why did
he sing the song clambake why did he
sing i mean these songs are dreadful and
you think he was elvis presley why
couldn't he
stand up and say i'm not doing this get
me liebert stoller get me real
songwriters let's make a real soundtrack
well i think one thing that happened was
that the colonel one of the ways the
colonel bolsterdale was his confidence i
mean there are these letters that he
wrote to both elvis and to his father
while elvis is in germany in the army
and they're the most extraordinary
letters to bolster i mean elvis is just
in the depths
everything's over and the colonel says
look i've got this deal i've got that
deal when you come home we've got five
million dollars worth of movies lined up
but but to
but to uh
do the movies you've got to fulfill the
contract and i think that became part of
it but but the big thing to me was that
um
he uh
he made a couple of serious movies right
after he got out of the army he made
wild in the country
uh and he made um flaming star and they
were seriously antenna don siegel
directed flaming star
it was elvis admired don siegel i don't
think don siegel admired elvis as it
turned out but the point is i i can't
for the life of me
say why it is that in neither in those
movies or any others did he show the
flair that he had shown in those
pre-army movies and i think he i mean in
other words what he did in flaming star
and wild in the country
is you would say you're lying
and then i as elvis would just
i'd blurt out my line but there was no
sense that i was listening to what you
were saying there was no connection i
mean he and and i that's a hard thing to
say but i feel like in in many ways and
this is
i know it sounds simplistic or maybe it
is simplistic
his mother's death
duke ellington has had a similar crisis
of
confidence or you know when his mother
died he said he didn't write a note of
music i think either for a year or two
years after his mother died in elvis
case though it was almost a matter of
belief everything that he had imagined
happening
happened just like this one after
another there was not a false note right
from the time he first
made his first recording
up until he went into the army so from
54 to 59
it's really just an unbroken it's an
unbroken and it all happened just as he
sort of saw that it would and should
and it was all for not just for himself
but for him and his parents for his
family and then his mother dies
and he spent the rest of his life trying
to figure out
why did this happen what does this mean
what's my function on earth i mean and
and he explored garcia he explored all
kinds of uh
new age religions he wanted to join the
self-realization fellowship i i met
diamata who was a very serious woman you
know who was the head of the
self-realization fellowship which it
started out with with autobiography for
yogi swamy
i can't pronounce his name but um
and elvis wanted to be a monk this was
you know he was serious enough about
that but i mean he was in total pursuit
of the of the answer which of course is
always a bad idea since you know you're
unlikely to find the answer but i i have
but i'll you tell me when are you going
to tell me after we're done
i'll take you to a special cave
but
so he so
he he gets back from the army you've got
this period of these movies which are
increasingly dreadful in my opinion and
and you know i listen to
elvis every night practically on sirius
radio there's an elvis channel and i
love it but then every now and then they
say now we're gonna go to the movie
soundtrack uh show and they they play
the songs from the movies
and i switch the channel i can't take it
and uh
because it's elvis
digging a ditch it's not something he
wants to be doing he's doing his best
but
um
artists like elvis who survived into the
80s
got a chance to work with rio and 90s
get a chance to they're redeemed they
get to work with great producers
who you know johnny cash gets this whole
resurgence roy orbison gets a resurgence
they're
taken seriously they're treated
appropriately as icons and heroes and
they
their their work is refurbished do you
know what i mean there's that beautiful
black and white special with royal
everybody plays on
there's always part of me that's very
sad that elvis couldn't have
lived
to
[Music]
see
how great his work was you know what i
mean
to see how i know that he knew that he
was loved and and idolized but
to see that whole generation
uh
come out
and play with him and support him do you
know what i mean and and let him know
that his work was that he was the king
of rock and roll which can sound like a
a carnival title
but
that
he was someone who was revered and that
his work really meant something in the
american tapestry you know and that i
don't think he ever got that chance i
mean well i think the fact is that he
hit the last five four or five years of
his life he was what could be called
clinically depressed and i'm not not not
having my even my honorary doctorate i i
feel reluctant to you know give that
diagnosis but
but uh
i i think that were he to look were you
able to look back on on from the vantage
point of the present day he would be
enormously gratified at how seriously
his music
is taken at this point but i think one
of the things that happens uh and
it's because of the movies it's because
of a lot of career moves
but is you tend to miss the miss the
musical high points the ev the evolution
of elvis music in any number of
different directions
after he got out of the army so that
when he comes out of the army he becomes
a ballot singer yeah in a way that he
had always that's how he described
himself when he first met sam phillips
and he sings these beautiful ballads by
don robertson by doc thomas and mort
schumann i mean he sings in in viva las
vegas which to me is
i i mean i've never liked well it
doesn't make any difference whether i
like it or i don't but the point is i'm
just not speaking as a fan yeah but he
does this song i need somebody to leave
to lean on a dog promise and watch human
song and it's absolutely gorgeous
then
one of the things that happened and one
of the worst aspects of the movie
experience
was between 64 and mid-66 he never went
in the recording studio except
to record the movie songs now the reason
was not because the movies were killing
him the reason was because the what he
was wanted to do every waking moment
morning noon and night was to study his
religious texts and that's what he did
the colonel
who had no
real input into elvis's creative life i
mean he suggested one song um
um you know as i'm standing here the
stage is bare oh yeah yeah yeah
um
that was the only sign was the genie you
learned something lonesome tonight which
gene austin whom the colonel had a lot
to do with at once had sung in his
career
the colonel realizes that they're that
they're falling down on their
contractual obligations to rca that
and the colonel comes up with the idea
of elvis recording
a gospel album which was always closed
that's what brought him back into the
studio he recorded how great thou art
and that's what brought him while he was
recording that he's doing all these
other songs like down in the alley i
mean
he just would go from one to the other
that essentially what began his
regeneration in music which led to
6868 special and to
his recording in memphis in 69 with
chip's moment which was the one time
after a working at sun that he worked
with a producer who was really going to
challenge him and then he's got i mean
suspicious minds and uh
he's back he's back and he's
there's a period of time in the late
from the comeback special
into the early 70s where he really feels
like he's rejuvenated he's totally
engaged and he's engaged because the
shows the vegas shows challenge him
uh he's interested and then your thought
is that sometimes 73 70 70
72 73 i mean you listen to the music
that he's singing it's totally
depressing
it's an expression of the end of his
marriage it's an expression of a lot but
it's really an expression of depression
yeah and i mean it never come and and
you never get that
engagement again and he has nobody
he's you know he's got his memphis mafia
and but there's
nobody can
there's nobody there to shake him and
give him the bad news there's nobody
there to say you need help there's
nobody and and the other thing i've
always remembered or thought about elvis
is now we live in this culture where
people are sick
or addicted and they get help and it's
as it's the most common thing in the
world just for people to get together
there's whole tv shows and there's a
whole culture of
of you need help we need to talk in
intervention interventions and then this
is
almost this is before
that's acceptable that it's before and
not that elvis would have had the
personality to be able to confront that
anyway but you feel like this is before
that culture
was up and running was that right you're
right but but one of the things that the
odd things that happened is that all
these different people
his father for instance tried to
confront him
who was paying his father's salary
elvis yeah right dr nick who's gotten
the worst rap of all and who as dr nick
himself this was elvis's doctor dr nick
would say well i was an enabler and he
was right
but he made a real attempt to confront
elvis he was on elvis payroll he was on
his plane
red west
i mean i'm not speaking these are not i
mean all these people
made an attempt in their own way in
their own imperfect way i mean as you
say there was not a culture of
intervention and the main thing was that
there was nobody outside of elvis's
world
who had any input with him right so that
you know
uh
you know you don't like it there's a
door right and he could say that to his
father he could say it to you know his
doctor he could say it to the guys who
worked for him but but there was a
genuine attempt in on many in many ways
by people who loved him
to tell him the truth
uh it was a complete failure right but
but i but you know you think about it
i i'm sure you've seen this in your life
i've certainly seen it in my life
and i
you know i've seen i've had friends
who have fallen on hard times in any
number of ways whether you call it
whether it's depression or it's drugs or
whatever it is and you make an attempt
to intervene and you think well i know
what should be should be happening here
and you you're operating within a within
the context of a culture that knows what
an intervention is
sometimes it works but most of the time
it does right right so i i feel like
there were there were certainly people
who were just along for the ride but
there were an awful lot of people who
were sincerely concerned about i was
vernon i mean the the thing that killed
me
the most i think in writing the second
volume careless love
was the scene where vernon is just
looking
at his dead son or just you know and
it's just it's just kind of like
i mean it used to make me every time i'd
think about it would make me cry but it
was just like he's he's it's just i've
done everything i i did everything i
could i tried to protect you i did i
mean he did i forget what exactly it was
that he said and it's just devastating
and he he was a person of
limited sophistication yeah well
careless love is
great and fantastic and extremely
difficult to read it's the opinion your
subtitle for it was the uh the unmaking
the unmaking of elvis presley and
that book broke my heart because uh
you know
the first volume is all about the
explosion and the ascent and then
second volume is the
you know
um
so much of the second volume the second
half of the second volume is is uh
everything coming apart and
in this slow tortuous way and i i've
found that book very difficult to read
it's it's very it's a very sad story it
was hard it was hard to
write it was but it's like that ford
maddox four this is the saddest story
yeah and it ended and it is i tried to
technically it was really a challenge
because what i tried to do was to vary
it i what i wanted to do is to create
the illusion that this time it may come
out different yeah you know you think
you know at the end maybe he's maybe
he's not going to die this time maybe
it's in so for instance i began the book
not with him in germany utterly
depressed which is the second chapter
but with him coming back to this country
kissing the ground when he arrives in
memphis going into the studio with just
these unbelievable
you know ambitions and aspirations and
achieving them and i tried to sustain
that and then using the colonel who whom
i very much liked i mean he was a
fascinating guy i have to ask you about
the colonel yeah because you
got closer to the colonel than anybody
what about that but well any i don't i
don't i don't know another writer that
that that
got that close to the colonel who didn't
let people in
and uh
what was your
take on the man i mean did he after he
lived many years after elvis died
um did he ever was he ever able to put
what he and elvis did together into
perspective
the colonel was you know elvis chose
colonel parker it was not the other way
around
even as a as a uh 20 year old
and for all the loyalty that elvis felt
to sam phillips and to what he had done
he saw the colonel as being the one
person who could take him into other
worlds the worlds he wanted to go to so
and it was a partnership that worked
very well for many years one of the
great things about the partnership
was
that everybody in hollywood everybody
everywhere they went and the way you
described the steve allen thing
took them as total yokels
each of them
both colonel and elvis
and the two of them
played their roles it was it was they
were like mr inside mr outside in a
certain sense but and just chortled i
mean and took took these guys who were
taking them for ropes for everything
that they had i mean hal wallace i mean
i found all this correspondence from hal
wallace who produced many of who was the
first person to sign elvis to a movie
contract and produced many of his films
he was ready to just tear his hair out
to kill himself over the ways over and
over again in which he got taken
contractually by somebody he felt so
superior to but the thing with the
colonel was that he he was a
the wonderful thing about i i mean he
loved elvis i mean in his own way but
but it was in his own way
but the wonderful thing about
whatever interaction i had with him it
was like playing chess and it was like
playing chess with a master
who whatever move you you chose you you
knew he was about seven steps ahead of
you yeah and my my initial contact with
him
uh after first meeting him was a
correspondence that went on for about a
year and a half and i mean i heard back
from immediately friend peter your
friend colonel
and it would be like
i would try to approach things in the
most circuitous manner trying to get
answers and he would just send me back
something
i remember one letter he wrote i feel
sorry for you peter i didn't know you
were writing a book about elvis this is
after we've been going around for he
said i feel sorry for you that's really
the word i sent him a draft for a thing
you know that's the worst
piece of historical inaccuracy i've ever
seen you know i don't think you should
publish it if you can't confirm that
every element of his truth i said you
know i wrote i write back to him i say
colonel you're absolutely right
i said you know but the thing is how is
anyone ever going to know the truth if
you don't say what and then he he just
volleys that right back at me you know
but but over the course of
of several years
while denying
that he would
that he would or could help because he
said i'm not a dirt farmer and i said
well me neither you know we're not i'm
not looking for dirt but you know it
would be
uh but he helped me in immeasurably and
provided all kinds of insights and
answers but they're all sort of subtext
but as far as his relationship with
elvis went
the the the peculiar thing is
nobody nobody knew
what went on in that relationship with
the exception of elvis and the colonel
nobody else was in on the meetings
and the people who were who
i think
uh
really formed
the um
portrait of the colonel that has become
you know the standard portrait yeah
are generally speaking and they're the
ones who also formed the portrait of
elvis's father vernon you know uh you
know it's like in the tony jo white son
claimed he had a bad back
without her pokes out yeah exactly but
they these were the guys who worked for
elvis
who
are
totally different i mean jerry shilling
is nothing like red west
red west is nothing like larry geller i
mean so esposito all these guys yeah all
of these guys are very different so i
mean i'm not tiring them with the same
brush but the one thing that i would say
is that both colonel and vernon saw them
essentially as freeloaders whether
rightly or wrongly i mean i i think it's
in many cases wrongly
and they did everything in their power
to get elvis to cut these guys loose
and it's not at all surprising
that the guys who worked for elvis
should have a less than altogether
positive view of elvis and colonel and
also if you're around a scene like this
you never want to say well i have no
idea what went on in that meeting
despite the fact that it's a closed door
meeting so you think that they have
turned they a lot of people who don't
really understand the colonel have
have more or less painted him in an
unflattering light well yeah i mean they
they'll paint they'll they'll paint a
picture of all the business dealings and
they may hit on the truth i mean in some
cases particularly towards the end
i i would say at the very end when
colonel saw
elvis fired fired colonel in 1973
because colonel said you can't act like
that on stage i mean elvis was on stage
he was completely stoned he's denouncing
the hilton's baron hilton yeah and and
colonel told him quite rightly you can't
do that and elvis said you're fired and
then they went back and forth for about
i forget how long it was two weeks three
weeks something maybe maybe not that
long
and colonel said okay fine i'm i'm
walking but you owe me 2 million i mean
which elvis did anyway from that point
on i would say
you know colonel's business practices
were somewhat uh
questionable in the sense that i think
he saw this is this could come to an end
at any minute and he took advantage of
it but
but uh
but but the main thing was that the
deals that they made they were
essentially
uh what do you call it it's not a
partnership but it's it's a shared
enterprise it's a and and basically
at a certain point colonel had no other
clients and i think was around 65-66
the deal that they made
was as a 50-50 shared enterprise for not
for everything but from for much of what
they were doing and that's not and that
many people might say well that's
terrible and maybe it is but but it but
it was it was an aboveboard kind of an
agreement and you can understand why it
would exist but but it was but basically
everybody i i
what turned me around
was
meeting colonel was really interesting
but what really turned me around and
turned me around as far as vernon went
to
was getting into the uh
the archives uh at graceland i mean both
the kernels archives which are just
unbelievably extensive and also the
elvis archives which are mainly up on
the grounds
and seeing
the correspondence surrounding so many
of the deals the contracts the
correspondence i mean i i want to write
i want to put out a book of colonel's
correspondence because i think it would
give people
it would just be i mean i would annotate
it how on top of everything he is yeah
and also how funny he is and how clever
he is and how again i'm not trying to
because he gets dismissed a lot is
because he is the guy who elvis is doing
a massive show
at the biggest hotel in vegas and the
colonel's in the lobby selling badges
and right and ribbons which and i've
seen the footage and it's you think
that's not
that's not what the manager's supposed
to be doing
that's uh but he was probably doing it
just as much for a fact as anything yeah
he was amusing himself yeah he was happy
to sell some balloons right right right
and acting like it was a carnival ride
that people were coming to see yeah yeah
no i mean he was a man of of many
contradictions and he was not somebody
who was ever going to reveal his
innermost self either emotionally or i
mean in a sense colonel's approach to
things was the opposite of elvis
approach to music in the sense that
elvis revealed a vulnerability and a
sensitivity that was antithetical to the
music that you know that what popular
music had been before him but colonel
wasn't revealing that at all right
but the letters are just unbelievable
you read you wrote a book uh
elvis day by day which i've which i love
because it takes you literally paging
through day by day what elvis is up to
it was really fun to write well it's
fascinating too because you just see the
whole arc and and down to the nitty
gritty to
you know uh i mean towards the end of
his life elvis is is playing
would feel to me like these podunk areas
like he's is you know he's he's touring
and uh
you wonder like these tours seem to be
taking them farther and farther away
from
cities is that true
i don't think so much cities i think
this was this was retracing the steps
you know familiar steps
of uh not of his earliest career but of
of the kind of career that he that
that country singers had
but one of the things was
okay why didn't he go to europe elvis
never toured europe and
you talk about him being depressed
and this is another would have been
could have
had elvis toured europe in the 70s
the pla they would have lost their minds
the europeans would have gone crazy for
him
uh
they always desperately
wanted elvis to tour
and
he never did of course the story is that
he couldn't go to europe because the
colonel
uh
couldn't travel because he was uh
not an american citizen right he was an
illegal immigrant he was yeah he would
come in under the dream act now yeah
but but but but i don't think that had
anything to do with it i mean the
colonel
was working with tom hewlett
uh i mean jerry weintraub often gets the
credit but tom hewlett was the person
who was in charge of the of the tours
and he was the person that jerry
weintraub went into business with he tom
hewlett had been in the uh concert
promotion business starting in seattle
with jimi hendrix and with big national
tours of the first of the big
of the big companies
and colonel had absolute confidence in
tom hewlett
and tom hewlett could have gone
but in talking to tom hewlett about it
i would hear the same thing that i got
by inference from the colonel which was
basically they were afraid to take him
to europe why
he'd get busted
because they could control what was
going on
in this country he could he could travel
with his doctor or his doctors
he had you know legitimate prescriptions
people the theory is that elvis did not
tour europe because they were afraid
because the colonel and
his concert
promoter were afraid of a drug bust well
yeah because i mean that was happening
paul mccartney's getting busted there
were a lot of bus that were going on but
i mean i i would leave the kernel out of
it because everybody's going to say oh
that's just the colonel he's just you
know looking for excuses but tom hewlett
was just a straight ahead guy
and he had no you know uh he would have
loved to have taken he and there was no
question about i mean the colonel used
the term
we can't guarantee elvis's security
overseas
and you can read that the way i think he
meant it i mean he was never going to
say it but but i mean elvis at this
point we're talking in the 70s now
earlier elvis probably could have toured
europe but he wasn't doing that he
wasn't until
1970 he didn't go on tour at all
uh he he
went back to he opened in vegas in 69
and then and
in 70 he did a brief 271 he really
started touring but i think that that
was that was what circumscribed his uh i
mean there was a genuine concern and
most of the people around elvis forget
about the colonel
if you think that he has a vested
interest in it uh tom hewlett um nobody
knows who tom hewlett is but many of the
people around elvis were aware that this
would be taking a risk that
because elvis just wasn't from certainly
from 72 on he just was not in control of
what he was doing and it wasn't that he
was joyriding he was taking you know he
was taking depression he was taking
downers almost exclusively that's what
killed him really i mean it was just uh
it impacted his digestive system i mean
everything
uh so it was not he wasn't having a
great time doing this right but it was
just adding to the to the sense of
of depression and of and the one place
that he seemed to get
some
joy although he always you know it was a
big movie buff and you know
doctor strange love monty python he just
loved it loved money python just
absolutely recite that in in concerts
which is uh
bizarre but uh but he loved that kind of
absurd humor you know he had he had a
photographic memory so i mean it's like
when as a kid he memorized uh i mean
just without making an effort general
macarthur's farewell address yeah he was
so admiring of martin luther king and he
could recite the i'll have a you know i
have a dream thing and then he could
recite marty python you know
but but really what the i mean the
peculiar thing is the tours
killed in the sameness of the monotony
of them on the other hand the contact
with the fans was the one thing that
seemed to lift him up even though it
became increasingly difficult for him to
you know fulfill their expectations on
stage so it was a it was he was caught
to quote the song he was caught in a
trap yeah and uh
uh
what he needed i mean was he was in
the hospital i think in around 73 in
memphis for uh uh he had a form of
glaucoma
and he
and dr nick brought in two psychiatrists
under the guise that they were
ophthalmologists who were consulting and
elvis immediately sat through it and
that was the end of that so there was an
attempt to get him yeah psychiatric
health yeah yeah
yeah
um
i
feel like
you can't talk about elvis without
talking about race mm-hmm
and and i know that uh
you said that sam phillips dream
obviously was to
record
uh you know
black musicians white musicians but and
and really bring the two together and
just make music yes that was his that
was his vision
elvis obviously
there was
controversy there were people that
initially heard him on the radio think
this is a black musician he turns out to
be a white kid
there's
a lot of
people subsequently who feel like well
he's co-opted african-american music the
metaphor for this the idea of cultural
theft
is basically a metaphor
for the very sense of racial exclusion
and racial prejudice that could be
uh upheld right up to the present moment
it makes sense on some level that uh
you know that to resent the idea that
it's through a white singer
that you should um
that that black artist should get you
know this recognition what sam phillips
saw and what i and what he saw from the
beginning and he recorded nothing but
black artists for the first five years
that he had his studio open what he saw
and what elvis i think also saw was once
this breakthrough was made once people
embraced the music
that the doors were going to be wide
open for african-american performers and
that's basically what happened you had
artists like little richard chuck berry
beau didley fats domino who up until two
or three years before would have been
confined to an exclusive what was called
then the race market right they were to
an exclusively black audience they would
have been big r b stars they never would
have gotten beyond that
they became superstars and you can say
oh isn't it terrible that you know
uh pat boone recorded uh i figured what
he recorded tutti frutti or something
yeah
just uh
horrific but but
the point is if we were to go around
this room or go around the world and say
who whose version do you remember right
nobody remembers pat boone's version and
as and as little richard said on
numerous occasions thank god for elvis
presley he could have said thank god for
pat boone because he had a he had a
co-write on the song
and probably the most money that he made
at that time
was i mean this is the music business is
based on ownership it's not based on the
record that's put out there right and
particularly for it's mailbox money yeah
and and and so but but the main thing
and the by far the most thing is rock
and roll i mean rock and roll is just a
it's a marketing term i mean you you
they're it's a basically it's f it's a
it's a
variety of folk musics that are sort of
put together under this term
that that became a way to sell the music
right uh but but the point is that
rock and roll just broke the racial
barriers wide open
i mean after that
there was no and and there never has
been uh yeah this is it wasn't the death
of prejudice it wasn't i'm not saying
that
but but the point is
the segregated markets were just forever
just busted wide open and that was
basically what sam phillips that was his
point that was his goal and that's what
i think you know he achieved and what
elvis achieved so i i know your other
book that we mentioned in the intro uh
dream boogie sam cook there's no you
don't think there's a sam cook unless
there's an elvis presley making that
possible
and he's a gospel singer who then breaks
into the
the pop world with you send me and then
he has this remarkable run in the late
50s and early 60s
but
is sam cooks i mean is sam cook someone
who you think falls in that category of
someone who was
helped by that oh i think absolutely i
mean sam cook wanted to like elvis
wanted to reach the widest audience
possible he didn't want in any way to be
confined right by one genre one type of
audience you know one class one race
and
that you know i mean the peculiar thing
with sam cook is what what busted
the market wide open in addition to the
segregated market
was ray charles's i got a woman which
came out at the end of 1954
and after a lot of inspirational music
prior to that i mean music like shake a
hand by faye adams or or roy hamilton
you'll never walk alone which is you
know
a rogers and hammerstein song from
carousel i think but it's
inspirational music solomon burke
started out with that but ray charles
would i got a woman for the first time
translated directly
a uh
a
a gospel song called um was just a
gospel song by the southern tones
uh it was based on ananias and
translated directly just assigned
secular
lyrics to it and with that once that
happened
everybody went for the gospel sound
little walter did my babe as a take off
on uh sister rosetta therapist this
train little richard was was signed up
by specialty for the same reason
and so sa this in a sense along with
what elvis did was was the impetus for
somebody like sam cook to cross over and
the thing that scared the hell out of
him
was what if he didn't make it yeah he
was his gospel star yeah he leaves to do
this so his first record he does under a
different name right as under as dale
cook and he was terrified
that if he didn't make it he couldn't
cross back whether that's true or not i
don't know but you know that that was
that was his great fear but his second
record or maybe was just i mean after
making that uh lovable i think as dale
cook he made you send me less than a
year later
and uh and it was a number one pop hit
he also is unusual he writes the music
he owns the
music he owns the publishing yeah
and then and then he started his own
record company started his own record
company and he's
and you know he's uh african-american
singer late 50s early 60s who's doing
that that was that was extraordinary
they had the foresight to do that he was
people say he was barry gordy before
barry gordy
well in a way i mean he was a different
kind of very good he was very good he
wasn't the artist too but he uh no he
had the good fortune i mean sam cook was
was just the most
visionary i mean i i don't think
i don't think you could run into anyone
more brilliant than sam cook he had an
analytic cast of mind that was just
extraordinary he was an intellectual in
many ways constantly yeah read
constantly i mean it was just one of the
great stories that i ran into was
talking to aretha franklin who just was
i mean she would tell you today
that she was you know just in love with
sam cook she loved all the cook boys but
sam cook was and she went her first her
first pop tour she went out with sam
cook
and he was reading the rise and fall of
the third reich by william shire yeah
and uh and aretha said i went right out
and i bought the rise and fall of the
third right by william shirey to this
day i don't as she would tell you she
hadn't read a page of it but she just
wanted so much to emulate sam cook i
mean that it was uh but he uh yeah no no
he he had a vision just of it it was
like elvis in a way except i think it
was more uh
intellectually based than elvis and he
just had a vision of reaching everybody
well i've watched a lot of uh
sam cook
on
talk shows
there's a lot of footage of
interviews and
so quick and so funny and so sharp and
uh
and witty and
really it's just a spectacular
personality and incredible like this
incredibly good looking
natural performer with a great that
amazing voice
did you ever see where he and muhammad
ali are on that british boxing
commentator show yeah and he wrote a
song for muhammad ali they wrote
they did a song together right he wrote
the song and he produces it's like hail
hail the gangs all here and yeah i
forget what it's actually called but
that's what it is they're doing it for
uh they perform it together and it's
really
uh impromptu
it's really sweet it's really nice
but um
sam cook is another one of those had he
lived you do you have a lot of questions
stories i think he he dies in i think
december of 64. that
crazily insane circumstances that to
this day nobody really understands
there's a lot of what else could he have
done what would he have done
yeah no i mean we i mean i i often think
with it with elvis
what would he have done if he had lived
i mean i i'd like to think
were he to get
well you know i i'd like to think he
would have gone back to gospel music and
he would have found it enormously
satisfying with sam cook
i feel like he would have had some kind
of public role i mean at least that's
how you're becoming very interested in
the civil rights movement and
wrote and recorded change is going to
come and you know that was huge that was
a big change for it that was a big
change for he wasn't recording that kind
of music so well nobody was yeah it was
a huge thing and i mean what so what's
really interesting about a change is
going to come i mean it almost
immediately became
an anthem or the anthem for the civil
rights movement but sam almost never
performed it in public
now you could say one of the reasons was
that he didn't have the orchestration
and he wasn't good but but in another
way the song
in part i think the song scared him for
any number of reasons including the
explicitness of its message yeah so he
performed it the only time uh well i
think he performed maybe once or twice
more but the one
the one made main time he did was right
after he recorded it he performed it on
the tonight show yeah and the tape was
lost
well they unfortunate unfortunately a
lot of the uh
new york
tonight shows
uh with johnny carson were lost
and so there's all those great
performances that are gone
which is tragic but uh
yeah it was uh
there's that
there's that sense with sam cook and
with elvis where you can waste too much
time doing this but with both those
artists i
i spend time
obviously wishing there was a different
outcome but but uh
you know i think about this a lot with
with elvis specifically is
wishing
that
or
hoping
that he could have been well enough
to live longer and see you know
how respected he is by people
like you by intellectuals by people by
historians how he's
you know yeah achieve that status rather
than just
the
the uh truck driver who
the fable that he played a lot in his
movies
right the country boy who hits a gold
mine and it's all a fairy tale you know
no i think from elvis point of view i
mean you know and and certainly from
mine i mean that he was he from the very
beginning he was a conscious creative
artist he had a vision of what he wanted
to achieve
and he set out to achieve it and his he
and his aspirations remain constant and
i mean to constantly grow yeah and i
think that's the thing that the fable
tends to overlook i mean it's like the
fable
of the natural in you know in sports i
mean and so often you'll see people of
great talent i mean generally it's you
know african-american but i mean it
could be larry bird too
and you see people dismissed as somehow
they had this gift and that's what it
was but that isn't it but it's never
what it is i always say talent is
overrated talent doesn't interest me
nearly as much
as perseverance
you know and uh
that's
it's that drive you talk about
with with elvis that gets lost in the
shuffle a lot which is he was
um
talk about his legs moving
when he performed which was so
controversial when he first started
doing it people thought it was sexually
suggestive he just couldn't stop his leg
from moving right and you read those
great stories about him driving with the
band all night to get to a gig he
couldn't go back to sleep right he
couldn't sleep and that was a lifelong
problem
insomnia right and which he
self-medicated for which
you know
caused uh
you know probably started a lot of the
the problems with medication
he was so
he was just burned out by the age of 42
he had just burned himself up
yeah no i mean he was yeah andy and he
was uh and yet you feel that somehow or
other there were things if if you listen
to a song it was a song that the judge
recorded
for the heart
uh you listen to something like that
that he did towards the end of his life
and you still you hear that same
gospel infusion you hear that same sense
of i mean you don't hear it often in in
the late songs but there you see him
just
sinking his teeth into it and putting
the same kind of feeling into it that he
does into and that and that's what you
look for it's it's that
it's basically that that that's what is
so extraordinary about his music about
the music of someone like howling wolf
and this is this was
you know about sam cook is that they had
something essential to convey they had
something unique to convey and that
whatever else they were going through
even at his worst moments you can see
elvis uh
there's a moment where um i can't
remember what the song is now where he's
at the piano in one of the very late
performances
and oh is this where someone's holding
the microphone yes charlie hodge is
holding yeah yeah i know that i know the
performance i'm trying to think of the
song but i know that he's at the piano
and there's not even a mic stand right
right so charlie hodge i think is he's
like holding the microphone for him i
feel like it's a roy hamilton song but
but the point is he's just and i don't
even think it's it's not even that his
vocal is that
it it's not what it might once have been
but he is doing everything everything in
his power to put that song across he's
so invested in that song and that that's
all i'm saying is that's what that's
what carried him from the start and
that's what carried you know him and any
other great artist to the to the finish
and it's it
it was sam sam phillips's point
about him about wolf about charlie rich
about jerry lee lewis was
not that they were
uh
that they were that they were geniuses
and you know that there was no it wasn't
a question of they just fell into it
they didn't just fall into it they made
it happen because of the the depth of
their commitment because of the extent
because of what they put into it because
of the emotion that they just put into
if not every song you know every great
song that they ever did and that's just
not that's not a given with every
performer who comes along right it was
not a this is a career choice
that's choosing a career this was a
religious calling yeah yeah uh who's
your next obsession
well i mean i i'm
i finished a complete draft of the sam
phillips just before christmas and so
i'm just you know i'm just really
anxious to finish that up and then after
that it's vanilla ice
you know yeah i'd say vanilla ice was
probably
started out young with dreams and
changed the world i'm just looking for
the next challenge
that's a challenge hey thanks a lot
thank you that is it for this edition of
serious jibber jabber to see more
episodes go to teamcoco.com
sirius we'll also find a link to
petergaralnick.com which features lots
of really cool video clips and essays
about some of his
favorite musicians